the Twitter bombshell that really was
not so let me explain the back story on
this Twitter owner seems weird to say
that but yes Twitter owner Elon Musk
started teasing and promoting
a uh big bombshell related to censorship
and Free Speech
Hunter Biden and so many other things
and apparently the exclusive story was
given to journalist Matt taibi and so
Matt taibi published and we're going to
put it up on the screen a tweet thread
what better way than to break a story
about Twitter
than with a tweet thread Matt Tai be
tweeting thread the Twitter files now
one important thing to mention and you
can decide to what degree it matters to
you is it's logical to say why did Matt
taibi get this story
and if you look at his sub stack he says
he had to agree to certain conditions in
order to get this story to begin with so
we're going to evaluate whether this is
or isn't the bombshell that it was
expected to be but he says he got he had
to agree to certain conditions to get
some of the materials and rather than
explaining those conditions in the sub
stack post
he simply says I take my job and
journalism really seriously and you've
got to trust me you've got to trust me
okay so let's go to the Twitter thread
and when you look at it
uh he writes the Twitter files what
you're about to read is the first
installment in a series based upon
thousands of internal documents obtained
by sources at Twitter
the Twitter files tell an incredible
story
from inside one of the world's largest
and most influential social media
platforms it is a frankensteinian tale
of a human-built mechanism grown out the
control of its designer Twitter and its
conception was a brilliant tool for
enabling instant mass communication
making a true real-time Global
conversation possible for the first time
in an early conception Twitter more than
lived up to its mission statement giving
people the power to create and share
ideas and information instantly without
barriers as time progressed however the
company was slowly forced to add those
barriers some of the first tools for
controlling speech were designed to
combat the likes of spam and financial
fraudsters slowly over time Twitter
staff and Executives began to find more
and more uses for these tools Outsiders
began petitioning the company to
manipulate speech as well first a little
then more often than constantly now I'm
not going to go through every single one
of the tweets of his thread we're
linking to to it and I encourage you to
look at it but the long and short of it
is that what this bombshell exposed is
that people in the Biden campaign team
Joe Biden campaign team this was 2020
when Joe Biden was not president he was
running for president and Donald Trump
was the president members of Joe Biden's
team
would ask their contacts at Twitter
to remove what is essentially revenge
porn of Hunter Biden
we're talking about nude images of
Hunter Biden which were being shared
without his consent now is it
controversial
or problematic that there was a back
Channel being used in other words the
tweets that contained the material of
these images of Hunter Biden which are
against Twitter's terms of service and
are illegal in almost every state
revenge porn nude images shared without
the individual in the picture's consent
is it a problem that there was a back
Channel used rather than the public
Reporting System maybe and we can
certainly talk about that
but that is not a bombshell that is not
a bombshell and so this again collapsing
into not a non-story but not a very big
story at all they're talking about oh
this violated the Constitution for
example
there's nothing constitutionally even
involved here and legal experts quickly
explained that it's not even a
government suppression of free speech
because it was the Biden campaign it
wasn't even the government saying hey
you've got to act and remove these
images which by the way violate your own
terms of service as well as just about
every state law it was a campaign rather
than the government so that is the story
and you can be the judge as to whether
it is a controversial story or not now I
want to address one other element to
this story which is that there are those
on the right claiming that even my me
personally that that we on the left are
defending Hunter Biden or running
interference for Hunter Biden I really
couldn't care less whether Hunter Biden
goes to prison if he is found guilty of
some crime for which he is charged after
being investigated that's it the problem
with these stories is that number one
this particular story is about revenge
porn and content that violates Twitter's
own policy so this is not a story that
is really where you're going to get
Hunter Biden and then with regard to
other Hunter Biden stories or
allegations
he is not involved in the Biden
Administration the way that Jared
Kushner was the way that Ivanka Trump
was and others have been and so if you
can charge the guy with something if he
did something illegal by all means do it
charge him I don't know anyone on the
left who says oh no he should be
defended or whatever but it is becoming
that which the right says is constantly
wielded against them it's becoming a
Witch Hunt and Republicans plan to
investigate Hunter Hunter
throughout their coming two years in
control of the House of Representatives
absolutely bonkers the truth doesn't
matter they've decided this guy is their
target and so that's what they're doing
I've had such trouble finding a great
razor where I am not cutting myself for
getting those Nicks on my skin which are
so common with the cheap disposable
razors you have to meet our sponsor
Henson shaving Henson actually
manufactures parts for the International
Space Station and the Mars rover and
they are bringing that exact same
Precision Engineering to the Shaving
experience it hurts when you shave
because blades extend too far and thus
they wobble slightly but with their
Aerospace grade CNC machines Henson is
able to make metal razors that extend
just
0.0013 inches that's less than the
thickness of a human hair which means a
secure stable Blade with the vibration
free shave it also has built-in channels
to evacuate the hair and the cream no
more clogs no more rubbing your thumb on
the razor to get the hair out I use
Henson at home shaving is a great
experience now Henson wants to be the
best razor not the best razor business
which means you only need to buy it once
and it's awesome go to hensonshaving.com
Pacman add a razor and a hundred pack of
blades to your cart then enter the code
Pacman to get the hundred blades for
free that is a three year Supply the
link is down below